Olalah..je n'ai pas trouvé de jeu-vidéo pour faire une video aujourd'hui
OH-OH-OH
C'est moi le Père Noël, je viens tout juste du Pôle Nord, en Roumanie pour t'amener un jeu vidéal.
Oh, tu tombes tellement bien, j'n'avais pas d'idée pour faire une vidéo aujourd'hui.
C'est ça ma vie quoi.. c'est vraiment ma vie...
Oui c'est ça .*rire*
Aujourd'hui les amis, on est avec.. l'UNIQUE, Cyprien Iov *accent allemand*
Ahhhh et c'est vrai ! *accent mexicain?*
Je voulais même pas te serrer la main mais bon
Tu voulais faire quoi ?
Je te montrais de la main *éclat de rire*
Je suis très content de vous montrer enfin... pas un iPad mais
le jeu sur lequel je bosse depuis plusieurs mois
on est plusieurs dessus
et je suis très content d'enfin le sortir !
Ca sort aujourd'hui, vous cliquez avec votre doigt
pour le télécharger gratuitement !
Alors il faut savoir que tu n'as jamais vu une seule image du jeu.
Je n'ai jamais vu une seule image du jeu et je suis hyper content que je sois le premier à le tester
C'est un quiz et c'est un peu comme "impossible quiz",  "crazy quiz", tout ça...
Ouais
Avec des questions totalement débiles
Et un présentateur très très énervant
Ouais
Tu vas perdre très régulièrement
Ouais...
Finalement comme sur tous les jeux vidéos
C'est un peu le jeu de la rage
Ok
ça s'appelle le "nope quiz" et...
Ok c'est parti
Non c'est pas le bon
Avant de commencer comment t'appelle tu?
Euh pfff... comment on va s’appeler?
Allez Lucasfilm
C'est parti!
Tu t'appelle bien "verrue plantaire"
Ah il est fière de lui!
NON!
*Rires*
Parce qu'il faut savoir qu'il y a pleins de noms différents.
Voilà, donc, n'hésitez pas a dire dans les commentaires quel nom vous avez.
J'suis sur y'a un Easter Egg
Allez c'est partis ! Allez Easter Egg
Au bout de 200 "non" ça te met ton vrai nom
Très bien Verrue Plantaire c'est partis pour le....quizz !
Question 11 à 20, question 1 à 10
Ah d'accord c'est par palier de 10 c'est ça ?
-Oui voilà c'est ça ouais y a 3 vies par palier de 10
Question n°1
2+2 =
J'ai l'habitude de c'genre de jeux..mais j'vais dire 4
Parce que j'suis naïf et con
Y'avait pas de pièges mec!
Oh c'est trop bien!
"Ok, tu as compris le prin( cipe )"
Cette phrase je vais le remettre en replay plusieurs fois
"Tu as compris le principe du jeu, tu es très perspicace!"
Il est très mignon, j'adore cette tête
Eh bah très bien!
Question suivante
" Quel est cet animal ?"
Donc là tu m'as dit, replay:
Tu maintiens ce que tu as dit
"Girafe, éléphant, chauve-souris, mante-religieuse"
En plus la musique elle met grave le suspens *rire*
Bon mec, je sais, franchement on dirait une girafe
mai sait que ya un...
C'est quoi la douille?
Me dis pas que t'as calé une chauve-souris là-dedans ou une mante-religieuse ou un éléphant?
Moi je dirai la mante-religieuse
Ou l'éléphant
C'est ce qui me parait le plus drôle
Parfait, il me reste une vie?
Pff il t'reste une vie
Bah c'est parfait je fais long feu!
Bon, éléphant
"On reconnaît aisément l'éléphant grâce à sa célèbre trompe et ses fameuses échasses"
au c'est trop bien
mais y a aucun piege
"Classe les du plus léger au plus lourd"
Oh putain c'est drôle ça
"Une pomme en plomb, l'humour du présentateur"
"l'humour du présenta..."
On l'a pas encore trop vu l'humour du présentateur donc je sais pas trop où le situer
"Une pomme en pomme"
Ca pourrait être une pomme en raisin par exemple
Ca pourrait être plus léger qu'une pomme en pomme ou pas?
C'est que j'arrive pas à le situer
Faut juste classer dans l'ordre
Putain, les créateurs de jeux, vous avez un délire. Vous ne pouvez pas lâchez d'infos
je ne.... je suis...
C'est interdit
tel Jean pierre Foucault (x2) A je peut pas aider!
écoute
Une pomme en pomme
Ouais
Une pomme en plomb
Un tank de l'URSS
Ouais
Et l'humour du présentateur. Je suppose qu'il est trés très lourd
Hooooo!
"Laquelle de ces Barbies n'existe pas?"
"Barbie caissière au MacDonald's"
"Barbie secrétaire"
"Barbie Présidente des états-Unis
"Barbie nutritionniste"
Il y en a trois qui existe vraiment?
J'hésite entre "Barbie caissière au MacDonald's" et "Barbie nutritionniste"
Parce que "Barbie caissière au MacDonald's" c'est vraiment trop précis pour que ça existe
Après, je sais pas, on est toujours surpris
Bon vas y
écoute on va tes... "pououou"
Eh bah voila
Bon c'est la fin de cette video, merci Cyprien
J'ai vraiment pas envie de rager
Est-ce que c'est pas "Barbie nutritionniste" du coup?
C'est un peu abusé
Du coup, j'ai un doute mec
Bon vas-y nutritionniste
à j'vous ai dit c'était trop abusé
On apprend plein de chose en même temps
Mais c'est vrai, que ya des séries que j'aime bien
Il y a un peu de culture gé. eu débile
Je vais le caler souvent dans une conversation
Retiens ce numéro
Le mec il est distrait
OK, 189437
Y'avais un jeu comme ça sur DS que j'adorais
Et j'étais très fort
"En même temps, c'était facile, tu avais la réponse juste avant!"
ba oui mais mec c'est l'principe de ta question
Il se peut qu'il y ais des rening gag
Aaaa 189437, 189437
Notez le, je vais me le marquer sur le bras
"Quel drapeau n'existe pas?"
Ahh, un petit peu de culture
Je dirais celui à gauche
Celui-là, tout le monde perd
J'ai pris les drapeaux les plus chelou de la planète, j'en ais inventé un... et voilà
T'sais quoi?
Je fais un bisous sur ce doigt et je vais avoir beaucoup de chance
On a fais tester la famille, t'es le premier qui réussir
Ah donc je suis pas le premier à tester le jeu?
Choquer et deçu
Ashtag choqueretdeçu
"Lesquels de ces films ne mettent pas New-York en danger?"
"Star Wars 7"
C'est pas New-York qui est en danger
C'est bien, tu en as déjà une de bonne
'Tain, j'ai l'impression d'être en cours là, genre si je perd j'ai pas mon Bac
Qu'est-ce que je met?
"Thor 2 c'est New-York", "Cloverfield" c'est New-York, "2012" c'est toute la planète
"Man of Steel" j'ai un doute et "Volcano" j'ai un doute en fait
Tu as déjà eu trop de chatte avant déjà
Si je puis me permettre, ce serai bien que tu perde un peu comme même
Bon le doigt de la chance
Il est fort, il est fort, il est fort
C'est incroyable mais ça marche qu'une fois par question par contre
"Cloverfield" c'est New-York, il y a la tête de la statue de la liberté qui roule dans la ville
C'est sur, c'est New-York
Il y a un montage parce que ça fait vraiment 25 minutes qu'il est sur cette question
C'est incroyable
Franchement
"Man of Steel"?
Cet homme est très très content
C'est l'heure de la question
n°10
"Comment construire une tour?"
"Avec des allumettes", "Avec des briques", "Avec du ciment", "Avec un architecte"
Bon allez, "Avec des allumettes"
Il me fais plaisir
Il fais un AVC dès que j'ai une mauvais réponse
Architecte
Ah d'accord, OK
Bah "Avec du ciment"
"Avec des briques"
Ahh! je dois faire une tour avec, OK
C'est bon
"Quelle belle tour, as-tu songé à te reconvertir dans le BTP?"
Bien sur
Quand je biderais sur Youtube, bien sur j'irais dans le BTP tout de suite
"Admirable"
J'ai un cadeau
Ouais
Donc j'ai un double cadeau : j'ai le jeu plus le cadeau dans le jeu
"Tu as gagné un vieux bonbon trouvé au fond de ma poche!"
ça fais plaisir
Il fais plaisir
C'est celui que t'as prix, tu sais, quand t'as payé l'addition hyper cher de ton resto
Et que t'as jamais mangé
Tu la pris parce que t'as payé v'la cher
T'as payé v'la cher donc tu dis je vous prend un bonbon
"Lesquels de ces dinosaures n'ont jamais existé?"
Non! je suis nul en dinosaure mec, je te jure
"Vélociraptor" ça existe
Ah!! non, mais non, mais putain c'est pas ça
C'est pas ça la question
L'"Irritator" il dégage
Il y avais un irritator
"Hipsteraptor" ça dégage
le "Darwinopterus"
QUOI!?
Ah ouais, on a pris les noms les plus pété
Le Darwinopterus mon gars
"Il y a autant de lettres dans le mot vrai que dans le mot faux"
Vrai
J'étais limite, il y avais le timer mon gars
Mais je crois que je m'étais déjà fais la réflexion
Parce que j'ai rien d'autre à foutre de mes journée
Donc je m'étais fais la réflexion
Bah écoute je le savais déjà
"D'après ta boussole, où est le nord?"
Ouais, tu peux tournée le...
Tu peux tournée l'Ipad
Ahh, d'accord
T'es fort en...
-Attend
C'est ma manière de calculer
Il fais la macaréna t'sais
Le problème c'est que je ne sais pas vers où pointe l'immeuble
T'sais, j'regarde : attend elle pointe vers où?
T'sais avec le vent
Bon, quand t'en as marre de réflechir
Tu invoques le doigt de la chance
Celle-là
NOOON
Je crois que tu as trouvé le sud en fait
Mais non
Quoi!?
Le nord est là-bas?
Eh ouais frère
Évolution, je ne savais pas où étais le nord dans mon bureau
Le nord il est par là
Ça vas changer ma life
"Tu me donne quel âge?" "25 ans", " 35 ans", "70 ans, merci la chirurgie", "1000 ans, comme les momies"
"1000 ans, comme les momies"?
Tu me donne
25 ans ?
"Hi hi ! C'est vrai que je fais plus que mon âge, mais arrête avec tes compliments, je ne suis pas un garçon facile!
Le mec c'est pas du tout une dictature
T'es pas du tout obligé de dire : Ah j'ai l'impression que tu as 25
C'est pour ça que c'est un personnage assez chelou
Assez connard
C'est un présentateur connard
"Écoute l'extrait. D'où provient ce bruit?"
"Chewbacca", "Grincement de porte"
Eh! est-ce que le bruit de Chewbacca c'est pas un grincement de porte en vrai, c'est pas ça le truc
C'est un grincement de porte
"Ma porte fait d'excellentes imitations !"
C'est une porte à vous qui fais ça?
C'est une porte trouvé sur Internet
Le mec il fais rululu pendant 5 minutes
Et on fais : Ouah
Ah! Deuxième cadeau
"Une statue de bronze vraiment géniale !"
Qui ressemble étrangement au présentateur comme même
On se demande pourquoi il la trouve géniale
Les gains sont de plus en plus barré
Il y a même des trucs un peu obscène sur la fin
Eh bah voilà, on a fais 20 questions
Question 21 à 30, c'est parti
Eh oh ! on se calme, on arrête là tout de suite
On veux pas vous spoile
Les gens vont découvrir pas eux même
C'est la fin, j'ai fais mes 20 questions, j'ai envie de faire la suite
Tu veux pas me le... tranquille?
Tu peux faire la suite
Je le ferai chez moi
C'était très sympas, très fils de puterie
Mais aussi des petites connaissances donc c'est vraiment marrant
Attend
L'instant promo, tu as que 10 secondes
C'est le moment de la promo?
C'est gratuit
-7
C'est sur IOS et (6) Androïd y'a pas (5) d'achat inapt
N'hésitez pas (3) à mettre 5 étoiles (2) si ça vous à plus ça nous ferais vraiment plaisir (1)
Et il y as des mises à jour gratuite
STOOOOOP
Stop, c'est fini
L'instant promo est fini, merci d'être venu
Il y a des mise à jour gratuite
Il y a un season pass à 45 €?
Non, non, en faite il y a une partie des questions et puis on vas rajouter des questions
20 questions, 20 questions
Cyprien, aujourd'hui je suis fière de te remettre le trophée du meilleur créateur de jeu
On dirai vraiment un Cudor que t'as reçu de la pars de TF1
C'est moi qui l'ai fabriqué pour toi pour ton petit jeu
Je vais te le laisser
Ça t'as plus?
C'était super marrant
Y'a pas longtemps, moi j'avais joué à un jeu que des fans avais fait
où ils avaient modélisé ma maison mais genre, c'est incroyable
Ouais
Et là tu joues à un jeu qu'un pote à toi que tu connais depuis des années fais
C'est toujours marrant quoi
Moi, je suis content que ça te plaît parce que ça fais
des mois que je bosse dessus
Et qu'il ne veux rien me montrer parce qu'il voulais pas me spoile pour la vidéo
T'as vu aucune image
Du coup, maintenant, j'ai envie de faire un jeu mais j'ai pas d'idée
Il faut commencé, si on veux faire un jeu, c'est bien d'avoir une idée d'abord
Téléchargé ce putain de jeu
et puis voila moi je suis contant parce que j'ai appris où été le nord
Vraiment ça va changer la qualité
-C'est vraiment très peu de culture
Mais ça vas changer la qualité de mes prochaine vidéo tu vois
Oui, tu sais que le nord, tu vas faire : Oh ! J'en perd le nord
N'hésitez pas à télécharger le jeu et à vous abonner. Je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Merci d'avoir joué
Je vous dis à très vite
à très vite
tchao tout le monde
Pisse
Aïe